a super bass blast from the past sophia
grace and rosie back on the ellen show
and all grown up i know it's strange
isn't it
it's really weird i mean like it must
feel weird to walk out we were so
nervous
you remember this duo cousins from the
uk who went viral 11 years ago with this
[Music]
ellen made them daytime superstars the
pair racking up nearly 30 appearances on
her talk show over the last decade i
love nicki minaj right
do you want to meet her yeah come on out
nikki
[Applause]
including this memorable moment
performing with nicki minaj herself
[Music]
[Applause]
fast forward to 2022 and ellen had to
bring the girls back for one last chat
before she signs off for good later this
month and of course they gave us a final
iconic performance
[Music]
[Applause]
sophia is now 19 and rosie's 16 and
they've got big plans for their futures
i'm focusing on my music at the moment i
actually have a new single that's just
come out called little things
[Music]
obviously following in severe's
footsteps i am releasing a new song
[Music]
et actually caught up with rosie back in
2020 where she reflected on the journey
it's been really fun because i when i
was younger i never thought like i would
be singing and stuff
um to be honest i thought i was going to
be a vet but like i started singing and
i absolutely loved it me and sophia were
both different people we're obviously
cousins and i'm so proud of her and
she's so proud of me but sophia's like
more of a rapper and she's doing
absolutely amazing
[Music]
you